-Beautiful day in New York City.
Temperatures are climbing.
People are starting to
make summer plans,
and it's easy to get distracted
from the job at hand.
And for my writers, that job is
writing monologue jokes.
You may not know this, but my
writers write hundreds of jokes
every day just to get
the 10 or 12 we end up using
in the monologue.
And sometimes, to be honest,
I think they just throw in
a few stinkers to fill the page
and meet their daily assignment.
But just because the warblers
are back in Central Park
doesn't mean
we can tolerate laziness,
which means it's time for
another "Surprise Inspection."
[ Fanfare ]
So, here is how
"Surprise Inspection" works.
I'm going to read some real
jokes that were really submitted
by my writers that are
absolutely unusable
for this show.
Some are dumb,
some are offensive,
some are confusing.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this.
And because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know.
So, let's get started.
Authorities in Philadelphia
recently picked up
two goats that were spotted
walking through a neighborhood.
I'd tell you what the goats
said when they were arrested,
but we'd have to bleat it out.
A young man named Ian
wrote that joke.
He looks like this.
"Did you -- Did you get it?"
President Biden
is set to meet tomorrow
with the Italian prime minister,
where they will discuss
the concerning rise of anti-pa.
So, that joke is
about antifa and antipasto.
I forget -- who wrote it?
Can we take a look?
We're off and running.
Researchers at MIT
published a study this week
that details the best way
to split an Oreo.
And this is pretty surprising.
It's with your butt cheeks.
Like, so, we --
Somebody we pay money to
says, "I got a computer."
And they're like, "Okay.
I'll show this to my boss."
Let's take a look at Matt.
Matt wrote that. There you go.
Ooh.
Today was
Manatee Appreciation Day,
so give 'em some props.
[ Audience groans ]
Kind of miss the butt cheeks
a little bit?
Kind of remembering the good old
days of the butt-cheek Oreos?
Brian wrote that.
A couple in Massachusetts
was recently awarded
nearly $5 million in a lawsuit
against a local country club
after enduring years of golf
balls crashing into their home.
This after the club
only offered them "fore!"
[ Breathes deeply ]
So, that joke
required you to remember
that they settled for $5 million
and then the whole joke,
and then it got to "fore."
And that was --
Hey, you know what?
That was Brian.
Why don't we give him
some props.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
Authorities in Florida
recently arrested a man
who allegedly stole
a crossbow from a store
by stuffing it down his pants.
That or his penis
can shoot arrows.
Karen!
"That or his penis
can shoot arrows."
I don't know if -- I don't think
it makes any sense.
"You don't understand!"
The worst is, that guy, the poor
man whose penis shoots arrows --
his wife's like, "We stopped by
the sporting-goods store."
He's like, "You know,
every time I go in there,
they think I'm
stealing a crossbow."
According to a new study,
having a long-term pet
may delay memory loss,
though the brain-eating parasite
in your cat's poop
may have other plans.
That was from Ali. There's Ali.
She seems very -- Now, if you've
been watching our show
for any amount of time,
first of all, ha!
Second of all, you know that
the worst offender
on our writing staff
when it comes to writing
terrible, unusable, monstrous
jokes is our writer
Mike Scollins.
Let's take a look at Mike.
There he is. Nope, that's Ali.
And that's Mike right there.
He once wore a tank top to work.
So, the thing about Mike is,
he writes really good jokes.
He's a very good joke writer.
But he has no middle ground.
They are either monologue-worthy
or absolute shocking garbage.
So let's just turn the spotlight
on Mike for a few jokes here.
I'll get through them
as fast as I can
so it won't hurt that much.
Russian forces have reportedly
placed trained dolphins
at the entrance to a port
on the Black Sea
to protect a naval base.
And they're still happier than
the ones at SeaWorld.
A man from Illinois
has gained attention online
after he claims to have found a
60-year-old McDonald's meal
behind his bathroom wall.
Also, Grimace.
Pretty good.
I mean, that's pretty good.
We could've done that one.
You know what?
I will say,
like, this is also --
Like, there's a poor
graphics department that, like,
Mike writes
these terrible things,
and then they got to go --
Like, that's their job today
is like, "Well, we got to put
the skeleton of Grimace
in a wall."
Netflix announced yesterday
it will develop five new shows
for preschoolers based on
famous Dr. Seuss books.
But you're not going to like
who's directing "Hop on Pop."
Guys...
[ Audience groans ]
He's right --
they weren't going to like it.
The Tony Award nominees
were announced yesterday,
and the musical "MJ" about the
late singer Michael Jackson --
So, guys, let's just
prepare ourselves.
Okay?
The Tony award nominees
were announced yesterday,
and the musical "MJ" about the
late singer Michael Jackson --
Because I think we should be
able to jump ahead
and be like, "Which part of
Michael Jackson?
What's the joke?"
The Tony Award nominees
were announced yesterday,
and the musical "MJ" about the
late singer Michael Jackson
received 10 nominations.
Well, it is supposed
to be touching.
Mike Scollins, beat it.
This has been
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Fanfare ]